bien sûr en direct de Kiev la capitale
de son pays et il va implorer Ottawa
d'en faire davantage pour le peuple
ukrainien c'est très important pour lui
de rester en lien avec les alliés de
garder ce contact de le rendre très très
étroit monsieur zilenski a déjà fait le
même exercice auprès du Parlement
britannique où il a été d'ailleurs
chaleureusement auventionné donc il
devrait remettre ça par la suite demain
devant le Congrès américain au menu
aujourd'hui donc il est prévu qu'à 11h15
le Premier ministre Rudo d'abord près de
la parole accueille avec un discours sur
homologue ukrainien il devrait annoncer
aussi de nouvelles sanctions contre une
quinzaine de personnalités russes et
rappeler aussi la proximité qui
caractérise la relation entre l'Ukraine
et le Canada rappelons que nous avons
ici la deuxième plus grande diaspora
ukrainienne en importance avec un
million 400 000 personnes descendantes
du crâne et c'est d'ailleurs la
troisième fois vous savez qu'un
président ukrainien reçoit un carton
d'invitation pour s'adresser au
Parlement canadien il y a eu dans les
années précédent
en 2014 quelques points après l'annexion
illégale de la Crimée et le début de la
guerre dans le don-basse il y a eu aussi
Victor hutchenko ça c'était en 2008 donc
pour marquer cet événement important
mieux comprendre les enjeux j'ai avec
moi le spécialiste de l'Ukraine
dominicarel et les professeurs à
l'université d'Ottawa et j'ai aussi
Louis Blouin qui suit tout ça avec nous
depuis tôt ce matin qui va être là tout
au long de cette émission spéciale c'est
notre correspondant à vous deux bonjour
en fait à vous deux seulement l'habitude
d'animer le soir
vous vous attendez à quoi de la part du
président ukrainien aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'émotions parce que les
grandes discours c'est les mots mais
c'est surtout la façon dont le message
passe et puis
baseline ce qui nous électrices depuis 3
semaines parce que il est très
authentique qui évidemment c'est un
ancien comédien alors il maîtrise très
très bien le verbe la communication et
puis voilà je m'attends un grand moment
était remarquable dans ses discours mais
non dans ses discours dans toutes ces
sorties c'est quelqu'un qui maîtrise
très très bien
l'art des vidéos de la communication
moderne aujourd'hui là où on lance dans
les réseaux sociaux l'un des
communications très touchant on a même
déjà comparé à Churchill ce qui n'est
pas rien
oui mais écoutez c'est un acteur mais ce
qu'il fait depuis 3 semaines c'est pas
c'est pas du cinéma c'est réel c'est
pour ça que le message passe autant
auprès de son peuple le taux de
popularité a dépassé des 90%. alors
qu'avant la guerre c'était en dessous de
40 c'est un politicien en guillemets
normal avec des opposants et tout et
puis c'est justement c'est
l'authenticité la capacité de de faire
parler littéralement ces tripes ces
émotions dans un évidemment dans un
contexte dramatique sans précédent parce
que Poutine carrément veut détruire
l'Ukraine veut détruire la souveraineté
de l'Ukraine qu'est-ce qu'il peut gagner
avec cette communication aujourd'hui
c'était allocution de volcanada
peut-être que les gains seront pas
immédiats mais d'avoir justement
cette attention dans un moment vous avez
mentionné c'est le troisième là
président ukrainien dans l'histoire
récente qui s'adresse à la nation au
Parlement
mais évidemment c'est le premier c'est
le premier qu'il fait dans une situation
de guerre dans un contexte de la
première guerre d'agression sur le sol
européen depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale alors lorsqu'il y a parlé au
Parlement britannique demain au Congrès
c'est ça qui fait l'événement si unique
qui nous parle littéralement de son
bancaire
mais je pense qui va jouer aussi
beaucoup sur la fibre très très profonde
qui lit le Canada et l'Ukraine vous avez
mentionné la communauté Ukraine la
deuxième plus grande à l'importance mais
honnêtement c'est la première parce
qu'il y a une communauté
ukrainienne en Russie qui est
démographiquement et plus important mais
à la pas plus jamais s'organiser en
raison de la répression
entre autres alors qu'ici au Canada
c'est une communauté qui est très
organisée qui est très présente et qui
fait partie de notre histoire vous
attendez vous à ce qu'il s'adresse aussi
directement aux descendants ukrainien au
Canada probablement
sûrement en fait sur écouter c'est 130
ans d'histoire
la première migration date des années
1890 correspond à essentiellement à la
au développement de l'Ouest canadien et
puis il y a eu quatre grandes vagues de
migration et la quatrième se poursuit
depuis 30 ans depuis depuis
l'indépendance ukrainienne
malheureusement de toute évidence il y
en a une cinquième maintenant avec les
réfugiés le Canada va faire plus que sa
part donc oui évidemment qui va qui va
en parler
il a martelé un message et les autres
députés aussi
Ukrainiens avec qui on a eu l'occasion
parfois de parler marteler le même
message c'est-à-dire cette demande
d'exclusion aérienne protégée le ciel de
l'Ukraine il se fait dire non de façon
systématique on comprend le risque
d'escalade qui est derrière ça la
communauté internationale qui pour
l'instant n'est pas prête à s'engager
là-dedans est-ce que vous vous attendez
à ce qu'il le redemande maintenant
devant les parlementaires canadiens
oui oui
va pas cesser de leur demander bon
est-ce qu'il va le faire aujourd'hui
probablement mais écoutez il le fait
parce que la Russie s'attaque au civil
c'est les bombardements indiscriminés
des villes on est au-delà de la
résistance héroïque disons là comme ça
de l'armée ukrainienne dans les combats
avec l'armée russe les bombardements de
ville c'est pas contre l'armée
ukrainienne c'est contre la population
civile alors le cri du cœur de Céline
ski c'est à dire il faut il faut
empêcher il faut arrêter ces crimes de
guerre ces crimes contre l'humanité d'où
la zone d'exclusion aérienne d'où on la
tentative d'avoir des avions de chasse
le militaire c'est pour ça qu'il le
répète
c'est justement ce qui rend la situation
si insupportable quand on est à
l'extérieur mais qu'on est un
observateur attentif de ce qui se passe
c'est-à-dire on ne veut pas de civil
assassiné évidemment dans un conflit
comme ça mais on se sent en même temps
coincé et impuissant
oui c'est très angoissant et mais je
pourrais dire
zellenski pendant des mois avant la
guerre ne cessait de demander des armes
létales les États-Unis ont donné un peu
mais c'était il frappe mur avec
l'Allemagne la France et le Canada le
Canada a refusé jusqu'à une semaine du
début de la guerre pour précisément
enfin l'argument c'était on veut pas
qu'il y a une escalade bon il y en a eu
une escalade puisque de toute façon
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre
d'agression alors ce qui semblait
inimaginable il y a un mois c'est-à-dire
la guerre d'agression la guerre tout
azimut le bombardement des villes ben là
on y assiste un puissant cette
imaginable puisque c'est devant c'est
devant nous 24 heures par jour avec les
médias sociaux pilotées alors lorsqu'on
dit c'est inimaginable que l'OTAN le
Canada etc pour accepter
de remettre en question là ce refus
d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
je sais pas je sais pas ce qui est
inimaginable maintenant le sera
peut-être pas dans deux ou trois
semaines qui sait alors zelens qui va
continuer de leur demander une dernière
question avant de passer à mon collègue
Louis est-ce qu'on sait tous
collectivement trompé finalement et sur
monsieur Poutine et sur la situation
c'est à dire vous le dites là on voyait
venir il y a eu une montée dramatique
dans les discours dans les attitudes
monsieur Poutine a répété des choses
qu'on a peut-être mal décoder ou mal
comprise
c'est clair c'est clair mais le message
enfin les signaux qu'on reçoit de Russie
de la part de des élites des élites même
ceux qui travaillent à plein temps pour
en politique étrangère dans les
instituts et tout c'est que aussi n'ont
pas pu venir parce que c'était
inimaginable c'est une chose de
d'intervenir aux Danne basse c'est
peut-être d'étendre la guerre au dan
basse puisque c'était le tiers du
territoire puis d'en faire une guerre
dans tout le territoire mais d'y aller
avec une guerre tout azimut comme ça
c'est on l'a pas vu venir on aurait dû
et puis ça des conséquences évidemment
extrêmement majeurs pour la suite des
choses et on n'a pas terminé d'en parler
des conséquences parce que bien sûr il y
a les civils bien sûr il y a cette
agression terrible mais après ça il va y
avoir toutes ces répercussions aussi
même sur l'alimentation mondiale parce
qu'on parle ici de l'Ukraine qui est
aussi un grenier pour le monde il y a
des pays qui vont souffrir par la suite
on aura l'occasion de revenir sur toutes
ces aspects là mais là je vais aller
voir Louis qu'on va retrouver justement
dans le foyer du Parlement à Ottawa
alors les parlementaires sont en train
de se diriger vers la chambre comme tel
pour se préparer à écouter ses discours
absolument on a vu beaucoup de députés
et aussi des sénateurs passés ils ont de
la place à l'intérieur des chaises qui
ont été ajoutées il faut comprendre que
tout le monde aussi aujourd'hui porte ce
fameux petit ruban bleu et jaune à la
boutonnière un symbole de solidarité et
puis c'est ça cet exercice là dans le
fond c'est pour les parlementaires de
pouvoir exprimer eux aussi leur
solidarité démonstration d'unités aussi
du Parlement canadien ce matin avec ce
discours monsieur Trudeau qui va prendre
la parole en premier Julie à part
compter 11h15 environ allocution il
commence ensuite la parole à Monsieur
Zelinski si on se fie à son allocution
par le membre britannique la semaine
dernière on pense que ça devrait durer
une dizaine de minutes on comprend que
Monsieur et linsky il y a des questions
de sécurité il peut pas rester devant sa
caméra de manière très très longue parce
qu'on sait qu'il est ciblé il est suivi
etc alors une dizaine de minutes selon
ce qu'on nous dit ensuite président du
Sénat qui prendra la parole quelques
minutes président de la Chambre des
communes et ensuite c'est là qu'on
entendra la chef par intérim du parti
conservateur qui me dise burgen suivi
d'Yves François Blanchet du bloc jogm
médecine du NPD et Elisabeth mai qui va
représenter le Parti vert tout ça
devrait durer à peu près une heure un
moment qui est oui très symbolique je
dirais même peut-être historique parce
que c'est rare qu'on a vu un président
comme ça un chef d'État au gouvernement
alors que son pays est en pleine guerre
venir prononcer un discours comme
celui-là son prédécesseur à Monsieur
Zelinski monsieur porochenko était là en
2014 ensuite après l'annexion de la
Crimée il avait fait un discours et à ce
moment elle avait dit on se bat pour
notre indépendance mais dans quelques
années plus tard son successeur lui
arrive ici alors que le gouvernement
ukrainien se bat pour la survie
carrément de l'État ukrainien alors
c'est énorme il y a des vies de civil on
le sait et qui ont été perdus déjà alors
c'est un moment très symbolique aussi
pour les députés d'origine ukrainienne
il y en a ici mais aussi tous les
Canadiens d'origine ukrainienne et
canadiens de manière plus générale avec
cette diaspora très importante que l'on
connaît effectivement au Canada bon et
le Canada ne voulait pas le recevoir les
mains vides déjà aujourd'hui ah non non
on a annoncé de nouvelles sanctions
15 personnes qui s'ajoutent à la liste
des sanctions canadiennes ce sont des
responsables russes qui ont selon ce que
dit le gouvernement et je cite permis ou
soutenu l'invasion de l'Ukraine alors 15
personnes qui s'ajoutent on est quand
même bien loin des demandes de Monsieur
Zelinski vous l'avez évoqué un petit peu
plus tôt cette exclusion aérienne pour
protéger le ciel ukrainien quand il
était devant les parlementaires
britanniques la semaine dernière il a
fait d'autres demandes aussi depuis plus
d'aide humanitaire plus d'armes létales
aussi mais il avait réclamé aussi que la
Russie soit désignée comme un état
terroriste alors c'est intéressant on
verra s'il va faire cette demande là il
cherche des symboles aussi monsieur
Zelinski on le sait alors on verra bien
où il ira avec ça mais ce Trudeau
effectivement ne voulait pas
l'accueillir les mains vides avec ses
sanctions de plus aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'il avait gardé ça dans sa manche
sachant qu'il allait prendre la parole
alors on va suivre ça maintenant il
faudra voir quel sera l'approche du
Canada pour la suite des choses il y a
ce programme de voyage d'urgence pour
accueillir des Ukrainiens au Canada qui
vont entrer en vigueur le 17 mars la
ministre des Affaires étrangères la
confirmé tout à l'heure alors à quelle
vitesse on va être en mesure
d'accueillir ces Ukrainiens au Canada
quel sera notre capacité de traitement
des demandes dans les pays limitrophes à
l'Ukraine tout ces réfugiés se rendent
ça je vous dirais que c'est les gros
point d'interrogation qui demeurent et
aussi est-ce qu'on va organiser des vols
des vols est-ce qu'on va analyser des
avions pour amener des citoyens comme ça
ici au Canada ça c'est encore des
questions qui restent en suspense
avant midi Louis de parler avec des
représentants des parties d'opposition
il y a quand même une certaine unité
dans la vision de tous les partis
derrière le gouvernement on sent pas de
fausses notes ici non ils comprennent
aussi parce que une des demandes de
Monsieur Zelinski c'est cette exclusion
aérienne mais tout le monde est bien
conscient que si des forces de l'OTAN
commence à s'en prendre à des avions
russes par exemple dans le ciel
ukrainien bah là il y a une ligne qui
est franchie à Madame jolie parlait
tantôt de cette ligne rouge on ne veut
pas que tout ça devienne un troisième
conflit mondial alors tous les partis en
tout cas ceux à qui on a parlé ce matin
nous disent c'est vrai il faut faire
attention il faut éviter une escalade
supplémentaire un appui je vous dirai
assez sanctions économiques coordonnées
depuis quelques jours peut-être ce qui
manque justement le bloc qui demande ses
vols pour évacuer les Ukrainiens ils
veulent avoir plus de réponses sur
combien et quand on va pouvoir recevoir
ces Ukrainiens au Canada qui veulent
trouver refuge et puis l'autre question
qui est soulevée par le Parti
conservateur c'est de savoir est-ce
qu'on peut expulser ambassadeur russe
qui est toujours en fonction au Canada
ce que l'on comprend selon les sources à
qui on parle au ministère des Affaires
étrangères du Canada c'est que on veut
éviter que l'ambassadrice canadienne en
Russie elle soit en perm mesure de
représailles expulsé et sans doute que
cette dame qui est là-bas a accès à des
informations qui sont très importantes
pour le gouvernement canadien alors on
veut sans doute éviter de se priver de
cette oreille sur le terrain si vous
permettez en Russie pour être capable
d'avoir des informations sur les
derniers développements avoir ce canal
de communication sans doute ouvert pour
laisser place à cette négociation
justement à ce dernier volet de notre
discussion monsieur Arel effectivement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous de ce
dossier de l'ambassadeur russe qui est
toujours ici au Canada et pour l'instant
la volonté du Canada de lui permettre de
rester ici
est-ce que vous m'entendez
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez justement
de cette décision du Canada de maintenir
les cadeaux ouverts finalement avec la
Russie maintenir ici la permission de
l'ambassadeur russe de rester sur le
territoire canadien
je pense pas qu'il faut briser les liens
diplomatiques même en situation de
guerre comme ça tout de même la Russie
est pas en guerre contre le Canada la
Russie est en guerre contre l'Ukraine et
l'Ukraine est en dialogue avec la Russie
même s'il faut être très réaliste
quant aux possibilités d'un règlement à
court à court terme alors c'est très
important de maintenir les canaux
ouverts parce que ça aurait quoi comme
conséquence effectivement si on
expulsait parce que certains partis le
demandent Louis nous le faisait nous en
faisant un compte rendu parce
conservateur entre autres qui soulève
des questions là-dessus quelle
conséquences ça aurait de dire mais
c'est terminé là vous vous quittez vous
ambassadeur de la Russie
les conséquences justement c'est qu'il
le Canada à ce moment-là aurait
absolument aucun aucune façon officielle
de communiquer avec la Russie sur ce
dossier là ou sur d'autres dossiers
parce que c'est pas évidemment le seul
dossier c'est le dossier de très loin le
plus fondamental mais il y en a d'autres
lorsque la question de l'article entre
autres et donc c'est c'est seulement
qu'en situation de guerre est carrément
en gare contre la Russie comme à
l'époque la deuxième guerre mondiale que
les relations diplomatiques sont coupées
j'aimerais que vous nous parliez aussi
de la diaspora ukrainienne qui est déjà
ici on sait qu'il y a bien des gens qui
s'activent enlevant la main en disant
moi je serais prêt à recevoir des
réfugiés de mon pays d'origine ou du
pays de mes parents quel poids ils ont à
votre avis sur les décisions
actuellement et le positionnement actuel
du gouvernement dans ce conflit avec la
Russie
je pense que là quand j'ai mentionné
plutôt que c'était la commune la
diaspora la plus importante diaspora
ukrainienne ne plus importante au monde
c'est justement en raison non seulement
de l'histoire mais aussi de son poids
politique qui ne cessé d'augmenter en
fait depuis 20 ans il y avait eu la
révolution orale avec usainco en 2004 et
puis bon my dan l'annexion de la Crimée
la garde basse il y a une particularité
dans notre échiquier politique où les
élections sont tellement serrées on a
beaucoup maintenant de gouvernement
minoritaire le poids et électoral de la
communauté Canada ukrainienne et est
important
peut-être même dans une douzaine de
circonscriptions ça
ça fait en sorte qu'en fait il y a une
espèce de consensus entre les grands
partis politiques ça date pas de
déclenchement de la gare mais ça date je
dirais d'une vingtaine d'années les
conservateurs les libéraux le mdp même
le bloc donc il y a cette
unité en fait d'être plus pro ukrainien
plutôt que de chercher un terrain
d'entente entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
ce qui était la dynamique pour donner un
exemple de la politique allemande en
fait au moins jusqu'au déclenchement de
la guerre et ce qui est particulier je
vais revenir à Louis Blouin qui est
toujours au Parlement Louis mais c'est
que la ministre vice première ministre
en fait madame freelin elle-même être
descendant ukrainienne alors ça colore
un peu aussi l'intervention canadienne
elle parle ukrainien on l'a vu
d'ailleurs s'adresser à la diaspora
parlé dans la dans sa langue d'origine
ou la langue de ses parents finalement
et c'est intéressant de voir à quel
point Justin Trudeau a laissé de
l'espace à Madame Freeland aussi il sait
très bien qu'il y a pas mieux informé
quel sur cette prise là elle a beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus elle a fait des
études même quand elle était en Russie
elle-même à ce moment-là alors elle
connaît très bien ce milieu là elle se
fait un peu le porte étendard d'une
certaine façon de la communauté
ukrainienne également alors c'est clair
que Madame madame madame fullin a joué
un rôle central dans tout ça on sait que
ça lui fait pas mal de choses dans son
assiette actuellement et je pense que ça
commence
leur très solennais très officiel comme
on l'a dit on écoute tout de suite
ensemble monsieur Harel Louis puis on se
retrouve après
qui ont fait en sorte qu'il soit
possible pour nous d'écouter le
président zellinski soit à partir d'ici
à la chambre soit à partir d'un lien
vidéo monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président ami et
collègues bonjour et merci d'être ici
aujourd'hui pour accueillir un dirigeant
courageux et exceptionnel
je peux
au nom des parlementaires et de tous les
Canadiens chez l'honneur de vous
accueillir ici en cette Chambre
monsieur le Président
vous êtes un ami
les Canadiens et les Ukrainiens sont
amis
et le son depuis longtemps
nos peuples ont une histoire commune
au début du 20e siècle une grande vague
du crayon à immigrer au Canada
la plupart d'entre eux se sont installés
dans les Prairies canadiennes ils sont
travaillés la terre ils ont construit
des églises qui se distinguent par leur
magnifique flèche
et ils ont aidé à façonner le Canada de
nombreuses façons compte aujourd'hui un
point 4 millions de Canadiens d'origine
ukrainienne ce qui constitue la deuxième
plus grande diaspora ukrainienne au
monde que ce soit en tant qu'agriculteur
scientifique leader communautaire
athlète ou travailleur de première ligne
les Canadiens d'origine ukrainienne
continuent d'apporter une immense
contribution à notre pays
mais l'amitié entre le Canada et
l'Ukraine ne repose pas seulement sur
cette histoire commune elle repose aussi
sur nos valeurs communes
depuis les années que je vous connaisse
j'ai toujours considéré que vous étiez
un champion de la démocratie
et maintenant les démocraties partout au
monde sont chanceux de vous avoir comme
champion
[Applaudissements]
votre courage et le courage de votre
peuple nous inspire tous vous défendez
le droit des Ukrainiens de choisir
leur propre avenir et se faisant vous
défendez les valeurs
que sont les piliers de
qui sont les piliers de tous les pays
libres et démocratiques
liberté droit de la personne justice
vérité
rien du tout
autant de valeur pour lesquelles vous
risquez votre vie alors que vous
combattez pour l'Ukraine et
l'usukrainiens mais au-delà de cela vous
inspirez également les démocraties et
les chefs démocratiques partout au monde
d'être plus courageux plus unis
et de se battre encore plus fort pour ce
en quoi il le croit vous nous rappeler
que les amis sont toujours plus forts
ensemble
avec nos alliés partenaires nos imposons
des sanctions accablantes sur Poutine et
ses appuis en Russie en Belarus afin
qu'ils soient responsable de leurs
actions aujourd'hui avec nos partenaires
de l'Union européenne je puisse annoncer
que nous avons imposé de nouvelles
sanctions très lourdes sur 15 nouveaux
représentants réussis compris des
représentants des élites militaires et
du gouvernement complices dans cette
guerre illégale en lui fournissant de
l'équipement militaire ainsi que de
l'aide financière et humanitaires et on
va être là pour aider à rebâtir une fois
que l'agresseur sera repoussée
au Canada
nous aimons encourager le plus petit
nous croyons que lorsqu'une cause est
juste et bonne elle gagnera toujours peu
importe la taille de son adversaire
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce serait
facile
les Ukrainiens appelaient déjà un coup
humain un calcul
cette guerre illégale et
inutile est une grave erreur de la part
de Poutine qui doit s'arrêter maintenant
[Applaudissements]
le mépris flagrant de Vladimir Poutine
pour la vie humaine est absolument
inacceptable le Canada continue d'exiger
que la Russie cesse de cibler les civils
et mettent fin à cette guerre
injustifiable
défile autoritarianisme et les
parlementaires Unis en cette Chambre ici
aujourd'hui et vraiment tous les
Canadiens sont unis avec vous vous
pouvez compter sur nous comme ami vous
pouvez compter sur notre appui
indéfectible et maintenant chez le grand
privilège de vous présenter le président
de l'Ukraine notre ami voler des murs
Zelenski
merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre cherche
amis avant de commencer j'aimerais que
vous compreniez
mes sentiments et les sentiments les
émotions de tous les Ukrainiens
dans la mesure du possible
non sentiment nos émotions au cours des
20 derniers jours 20 jours d'une
agression sans précédent d'appart de la
Fédération russe après 8 années de
combat dans la région du gambas
pouvez-vous imaginer
imaginez qu'à 4 heures du matin
vous entendiez des explosions des
bombardements des explosions massives
pouvez-vous imaginer entendre cela vous
et vos enfants entendre ces explosions
ce pilonnage des aéroports de l'aéroport
de Tahoua imaginez
le bombardement de vos villes
pouvez-vous l'imaginer
des missiles
tombent
et vos enfants vous demandent que se
passe-t-il
vous observez le pilonnage des
infrastructures
et vous savez combien de personnes sont
déjà mortes imaginez comment expliquer
cela à vos enfants
comment expliquer cette agression sans
précédent massive
vous savez que ça peut annuler
détruire votre état vous savez que c'est
une guerre pour nous soumettre et au
deuxième jour de la guerre vous
recevez un avis un avis
que de l'équipement militaire entre dans
votre pays et traversent la frontière
qu'il se rendent vers des villes
des villes sont assiégées
encerclé
imaginez le bombardement de quartier
résidentiels d'école
la destruction de garderie dans la baie
de soumis
ça s'est produit imaginez
le fait que Vancouver soit assiégé
imaginé les résidents de cette ville
c'est exactement la situation
dans laquelle se trouve la ville de
Mario Paul
il n'y a plus d'électricité d'eau aucune
moyenne communication ils l'ont presque
plus rien à manger il y a plus d'eau
on cherche refuge dans les abris Antibes
cher Justin
estimez invité imaginer
que vous recevez des
statistiques sur le nombre de victimes
des enfants des femmes
vous avez entendu les parler des
bombardements
97 enfants sont morts depuis le début de
la gare imaginez la tour du CN à Toronto
pilonner imaginez qu'elle soit frappée
par des bons russes
bien entendu je ne souhaite la personne
mais c'est notre réalité c'est la
réalité avec laquelle nous vivons nous
savons que les bombardements
continueront nous avons une place de la
Liberté dans la ville de gerkiv
il y a babilia a également à Kiev c'est
là où des victimes de l'Holocauste ont
été enterrés ça a été bombardé par les
forces russes
imaginez
des installations canadiennes pilonnées
bombardées comme les nôtres comme nos
immeubles nos
sites
les victimes des familles sont décédées
chaque nuit est une nuit horrible les
forces russes bombardent de char
d'assaut
il frappe des infrastructures civiles et
le frappe des immeubles civils
imaginez un incendie dans un une usine
nucléaire c'est exactement ce qui s'est
produit dans notre pays
ville est touché
il tire sur les
le drapeau ukrainien je sais que vous
soutenez l'Ukraine nous sommes allés
amis avec mais j'aimerais que vous
compreniez et j'aimerais que vous
ressentiez ce que nous ressentons tous
les jours
nous voulons vivre
nous voulons gagner être victorieux nous
soit en vaincre pour vivre
imaginez
lorsque vous appelez vos amis
nous demandons de créer une zone
d'exclusion
aérienne il faut arrêter le bombardement
les bombardements combien de missiles et
d'attaque doivent avoir au boire lieu
avant
de
prendre des mesures
je comprends que vous exprimiez votre
grande préoccupation lorsque nous
parlons à nos partenaires ils nous
disent de tenir bon de tenir bon encore
un peu
on parle de des escalades on parle de
désamorcer
cette crise
on soutiennent nos aspirations à devenir
membre de l'OTAN mais on n'entend pas de
réponse claire
on ne doit pas nous ne voyons pas les
choses qui s'imposent qui sont claires
il faut répondre il faut que nos amis
répondent à l'action comme ça a été le
cas depuis 8 ans
je sais que vous êtes conscient de la
réalité je m'adresse à tous le Canada
a toujours été inébranlable dans son
soutien envers l'Ukraine vous êtes vous
avez été un allié fiable pour les
Ukrainiens l'Ukraine je suis convaincue
que cela continuera vous avez offert
votre assistance votre aide
et très tôt vous nous allez fourni de
l'équipement militaire de l'aide
humanitaire vous avez imposé des cinq
sens sévères
nous observons malheureusement que cela
n'a pas permis d'arrêter la guerre vous
voyez que Karkov car qui veut marier
Paul ne sont pas protégés comme vos
villes le sang Edmonton Vancouver vous
voyez maintenant que qui avait bombardé
Ivan que franciscke
attaquer notre pays
était a toujours été pacifié que
notre pays pyéloné et tout ce que je
souhaite dire c'est qu'on doit faire
davantage pour stopper la Russie pour
protéger l'Ukraine et protéger l'Europe
de la menace russe il détruit tous les
écoles les complexes
commémoratives les hôpitaux les
maternités les développements des
résidentiels ils ont tué 97 enfants on
ne demande pas grand chose on demande de
la justice un soutien qui nous aidera à
vaincre à sauver des vies à sauver le
monde et le Canada et
et chef de fil nous aide et j'espère que
d'autres emboîteront le pas nous
demandons davantage nous vous exhortons
de nous soutenir davantage de nous
souvenirs dans nos efforts et nous
remercions tous les amis les amis de
l'Ukraine les amis de la vérité
il faut bien comprendre à quel point il
est important de fermer notre espace
aérien contre les aéronefs Russes se
créent une zone d'exclusion aérienne
j'espère que vous comprenez que vous
pourrez accroître vos efforts vos
sanctions afin que la Russie n'obtienne
aucun dollar pour financer leur effort
de guerre
les entités commerciales ne devraient
pas donc opérer en Russie comme vous le
savez très bien
vous savez que l'attaque sur l'Ukraine
s'est offensive est une façon de
détruire le peuple craignant c'est
l'objectif principal de cette
intervention et c'est une guerre contre
les Ukrainiens que nous observons
c'est une tentative de détruire tout ce
que nous avons construit en tant
qu'ukrainien une atteinte à notre avenir
à notre nation à ce que nous sommes vous
canadien vous connaissez très bien
tout cela c'est pourquoi je vous exhorte
n'arrêtez pas vos efforts
prolongez vos efforts pour la paix pour
que la paix revienne dans notre pays
pacifique je sais que vous pouvez le
faire vous pouvez continuer à nous
soutenir
nous ne faisons partie d'une cohésion
antigard et je sais qu'ensemble de
concert nous pourrons atteindre ces
résultats je demandais également à la
diaspora ukrainienne du Canada
il s'agit d'un moment historique nous
avons besoin de votre soutien de votre
soutien concret
et nous espérons qu'avec vos efforts
concrets vous pourrez contribuer à cette
histoire
ukrainienne qui s'écrit rappelez-vous
qu'il s'agit
de l'histoire c'est l'histoire de
l'Ukraine qui s'écrit nous souhaitons
voir la paix vivre en paix
et donc je remercie tous les
parlementaires présents aujourd'hui
merci à tous les citoyens canadiens je
suis très reconnaissant vers vous Justin
également
je remercie les Canadiens
je suis confiante qu'ensemble nous
pourrons sûrementer cette épreuve nous
serons vainqueurs gloire à l'Ukraine et
merci au Canada
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président j'invite
maintenant non on aura
alors voilà les applaudissements nourris
une occasion pour les parlementaires
canadiens de démontrer leur appui leur
soutien leur amitié aussi à l'Ukraine à
la suite de cette allocution du
président
ukrainien à l'option dont je parlais
avec mes deux invités Louis Blouin est
avec moi et Dominique larel aussi
spécialiste de l'Ukraine politologue est
avec moi aussi monsieur Harel je vais
commencer avec vous c'est très fort la
façon dont il a commencé son discours en
disant je vous demande d'imaginer ce
qu'est notre réalité et là il s'est mis
à décliner à décrire les bombardements
qu'est-ce qu'on dit à ses enfants il y a
des morts et à faire des comparaisons
avec des villes canadiennes et si vous
savez par exemple Mario Paul c'est comme
si la ville de Vancouver était qui est
donc il cherchait vraiment à créer un
renforcer finalement ce sentiment très
très fort des gens entre les Canadiens
et les Ukrainiens
absolument et c'est sa grande force
c'est d'être capable de raconter la
réalité quoi raconter des histoires mais
des histoires réelles et nous disait
dans son dans son allocution je voudrais
que vous ressentiez ce que nous
ressentons
et je pense qu'il le fait de façon très
très émouvante en fait surtout lorsque
nous on parle de garderie on parle
d'enfants on parle de s'attaquer des
hôpitaux etc c'est la réalité
actuellement c'est une guerre contre la
population
comment vous le recevez ce discours
monsieur Arel vous qui est un expert de
l'Ukraine qui connaissait bien ce pays
qui connaissait aussi les ressortissants
qui sont ici comment comment vous le
recevez personnellement
personnellement ou en tant qu'experts
tout ce qu'on vit depuis trois semaines
quand je dis nous aussi les Canadiens
mais particulièrement la communauté
ukrainienne certaines d'entre nous qui
sont dans les études ukrainiennes ou
même les études russes c'est la
catastrophe pour pour les spécialistes
de la Russie de voir
cette guerre de destruction alors en
fait zellinski c'est comme un c'est
comme un tonique c'est comme quelque
chose c'est en fait lorsqu'on l'entend
parler c'est
inspirant dans toute cette destruction
le temps et jamais hargneux le temps il
y a pas eu de menace par rapport à la
Russie ou par rapport au peuple russe
qui malheureusement les sondages donnent
encore 60% au moins de d'appui à Poutine
etc c'est
c'est la grande force de
Zelenski d'être capable d'inspirer à la
fois son peuple mais aussi la communauté
internationale donc nous les Canadiens
donc en écoutant ce discours là ce matin
on s'est inspirés même si tout va mal
ouais même si tout va mal effectivement
monsieur c'est ce qu'il dit là je vais
enchaîner avec Louis Blouin il a dit on
vous remercie vous canadien pour ce que
vous faites pour nous mais ce n'est pas
assez ça n'a pas mis fin à la guerre il
est revenu de l'avant encore avec
l'exclusion de l'espace aérien ouais
absolument ski qui a dit écoutez nous
voulons vivre nous voulons vaincre il
faut des efforts supplémentaires il a
salué cette amitié entre le Canada il
sait que le Canada est derrière lui la
remercie Justin Trudeau personnellement
mais il a réitéré trois demandes
essentiellement dit il faut continuer
avec cette pression de sanction
économique il y en a de nouvelles qui
ont été ajoutées aujourd'hui je vous le
rappelle mais surtout il nous faut cette
exclusion aérienne il faut que les pays
de l'OTAN dit-il protègent le ciel de
l'Ukraine pour enfin assez terrible
bombardement qu'il a décrit pendant son
discours et ça nous prend ça on va
continuer de le demander il sait bien de
savoir que vous êtes solidaire que vous
êtes derrière nous mais il faut aller
encore plus loin l'autre demande c'est
cette demande d'adhésion à l'OTAN
monsieur zeninski le demande depuis des
années déjà mais il le réitère
publiquement parce que sans ça le raison
de cette clause du 5e article de l'OTAN
et ben si l'Ukraine faisait partie de
cette alliance et ben là les autres pays
serait forcés de venir à sa défense
c'est pas le cas on prend bien que les
pays occidentaux veulent éviter de
traverser cette ligne rouge de provoquer
un troisième conflit mondial qui a une
escalade mais lui réitère cette
demande-là il dit il faut que ça cesse
et c'est pour ça qu'il est allé de ce
message tellement fort pour il faut que
ça résonne imaginez-vous l'aéroport
d'Ottawa bombardé Edmonton Vancouver il
essaie vraiment de créer une connexion
avec le peuple canadien les
parlementaires aussi il faut comprendre
qu'il sait aussi adressé à la diaspora
ukrainienne au Canada il a dit on va
voir besoin de vous parce qu'on sait que
notamment il y a cet accueil des
Ukrainiens qui va se faire au cours des
prochains jours voir prochaines semaines
les gens qui vont venir ici
temporairement alors il en appelle aussi
assez nombreux Canadiens d'origine
ukrainienne ici au pays et on a
maintenant d'autres discours devant nous
à la président de la chambre par la
suite président du Sénat et ensuite ce
sera au tour des parties d'opposition
qu'on ira écouter aussi chacun leur tour
ils vont prononcer une allocution
monsieur Arel quand vous entendez
monsieur Zelinski revenir de l'avant
avec cette demande d'être membre de
l'OTAN est-ce que c'est réaliste est-ce
que c'est quelque chose de possible bien
les observateurs disent ça c'était
compromis qui va devoir faire ça doit
même faire partie des négociations
actuellement avec la Russie
c'est pas quelque chose qui va pouvoir
se réaliser vous en pensez quoi vous
écoutez je peux répondre d'abord de
façon générale ce qui semblait
irréaliste il y a un mois est devenu
réaliste c'est-à-dire il y a une garde
agression en Ukraine sur le sol
européenne
les crimes contre la paix des crimes
contre l'humanité mais l'agression pour
détruire un pays on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale qui
Ève a pas été bombardé depuis 1944 on
fait 78 ans alors ce qui semble
irréaliste et maintenant réaliste
la peur de l'escalade la peur la
troisième guerre mondiale elle est
réelle évidemment on comprend pourquoi
le temps le Canada en tant que membre de
l'OTAN est très prudent sur cette
question de zone d'exclusion aérienne
mais écoutez on voit des images
insoutenable de Mario Paul de harkif où
il y a 400
tours d'habitation qui ont été détruites
on parle des civils
si le conflit le conflit si la guerre la
guerre d'agression
continue d'empirer
et puis on assiste en temps réel à la
télé et en temps réel sur toutes les
plateformes maintenant de médias sociaux
au bombardement de quai
littéralement millénaire
je suis pas convaincu à 100% que l'OTAN
ou la communauté internationale le
Canada les États-Unis
vont pas peut-être changer de position
la destruction de la capitale on veut
pas évidemment on voudrait qu'un selfie
de demain matin mais malheureusement on
assiste à cette guerre cette guerre
contre les civils cette guerre de de
terreur en fait je vous interrompre
là-dessus la chef actuelle par intérim
du parti conservateur madame burgen est
en train de prendre la parole on va
l'écouter tout de suite
permettez-moi d'exprimer personnellement
mon admiration pour votre courage et
votre
leadership en cette époque critique de
l'histoire de l'Ukraine votre leadership
est très rare monsieur le Président et
il nous inspire tous nous les élus vous
êtes le leader de l'Ukraine pension
pendant cette période de critique et
nous sommes
en admiration
contre votre pays et votre défense de la
démocratie
pour vous aider
[Applaudissements]
les images que nous voyons de l'Ukraine
comme vous venez de les décrire nous
crève le coeur ils sont très
douloureuses à voir des familles
réfugiées dans des abris Antibes les
ruines d'hôpitaux et de maternité les
vieux qui cherchent ce cours et sécurité
mais on y trouve également une certaine
inspiration alors que des jardinaires
des hommes des femmes de tous âge
défendeurs patrie nous sommes témoins de
la force et de la défiance des
Ukrainiens qui défendent leur liberté
indépendance et souveraineté
les Ukrainiens ne se
lutte pas tout simplement pour se
défendre même non il défendent toute
l'Europe car l'attaque de Poutine contre
l'Ukraine est une attaque contre nous
tous c'est la leçon que nous a enseigné
l'histoire et que nous ne pouvons pas
faire abstraction
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pourquoi nous devons aider le
peuple craignant
de toutes les façons possibles le Canada
compte le plus grand nombre de personnes
de descendants ukrainiennes en dehors de
l'Ukraine et de la Russie pendant plus
d'un siècle ils ont enrichi nos
communautés notre communiculture surtout
dans les Prairies canadiennes la d'où je
viens le Canada et le Manitoba surtout
avec l'Ukraine et maintenant presque 1,4
ukrainiennes canadien ukrainien regarde
ces images leurs
âmes et leur cœur
espère et pris pour leur pays et leurs
ancêtres cette guerre d'agression
patente révèle Vladimir Poutine sous son
pire jour
un prédateur violent qui n'a aucun égard
pour la vie humaine ou les souffrances
il a franchi deux lignes qui après deux
guerres mondiale nous pensions ne
pouvait il ne serait plus jamais franchi
et qui assurer la sécurité de 8945
chaque jour il continue de mentir et de
tuer des innocents des personnes
vulnérables y compris des femmes et des
enfants
ukrainiennes et se faisant et il
continue de menacer le monde disons que
c'est une
cause il
s'en remettra au pire extrémités il doit
être traduit en justice il doit être
tenu responsable de ces crimes contre
l'humanité à la Cour pénale
internationale à La Haye
[Applaudissements]
pas d'une guerre contre l'Ukraine
seulement c'est une guerre contre le
monde libre et démocratique nous devons
défendre l'Ukraine ce n'est pas un choix
c'est une obligation morale le Canada a
été le premier pays à reconnaître un
indépendance de l'Ukraine de l'Union
soviétique et il est maintenant temps de
joindre le geste à la parole nous devons
faire davantage avec nos alliés pour
assurer l'espace aérien de l'Ukraine
[Applaudissements]
nous devons protéger au minimum espaces
aérien au-dessus des corridors
humanitaires afin que les Ukrainiens
puissent
s'éloigner des zones de guerre en toute
sécurité et afin que les d'humanitaire
puisse atteindre les régions assiégées
et le Canada doit faire tout ce qu'il
peut pour alléger les tracasseries
administratives pour accueillir les
ukrumiers en fuite bien que nous savons
que bien entendu nous voulons avant tout
que les Ukrainiens puissent vivre chez
eux en toute sécurité dans ce pays
souverain et pacifique
[Applaudissements]
sachez que le Canada sera un refuge pour
les
Ukrainiens qui choisissent de venir ici
en attendant la fin et pendant qu'ils
seront au Canada nous prendrons soin de
nous leur offrirons espoir et lorsque le
temps sera venu il pourront retourner à
leur mère patrie et à leur famille
l'Ukraine c'est ce que nous vous
promettons aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
pas plus craignant je conclus en disant
ce qui suit tout simplement les
Canadiens vous appuyer aujourd'hui face
à Poutine et ses ambitions
les conservateurs sont unis avec
l'Ukraine et nous continuons de vous
appuyer
jusqu'à la toute fin lorsque vous
pourrez en faire reconstruire vos
maisons et vos communautés votre courage
et votre force face à l'université nous
inspire tous cela va Urani gloire à
l'Ukraine gloire au héros continue de
lutter de croire et d'espérer
thank you merci Madame Bergen le chef du
Bloc québécois monsieur Yves Françoise
Blanchet nous adresser la parole merci
monsieur le Président
estimé collègues monsieur le Président
et surtout monsieur le président
il m'est difficile aujourd'hui de
m'exprimer de simples mots qui ne
peuvent pas porter ou exprimer toute la
tristesse toute l'indignation toute la
colère que suscite la guerre sale
infligée à votre garde nation à votre
grand peuple il est difficile d'admettre
une certaine impuissance aussi une
impuissance à faire beaucoup plus
qu'exprimer notre compassion notre désir
qui n'est que l'ombre du vôtre de nous
réveiller tous de ce cauchemar qui
habite nos écrans au quotidien
bien sûr
la nation québécoise je crois pouvoir le
dire la nation québécoise est
massivement derrière vous derrière votre
peuple
bien sûr nous avons demandé et soutenons
que le Canada agisse de la seule façon
valable en concertation avec les pays
libres du monde et avec les grandes
organisations internationales tant
économiques que militaire humanitaire
bien sûr nous appelons aussi la
distanction économique toujours plus
sévère afin que ce soit de l'intérieur
même de la Russie et par la négociation
équilibrée que viennent la fin de cette
agression insensée
nous insistons auprès du gouvernement
canadien pour que soit elle léger les
obstacles à l'accueil de réfugiés
d'origine
ukrainienne
tant du Québec que du Canada il y a des
gens il y a des familles il y a des
ressortissants qui veulent accueillir
ces réfugiés
il faut aussi que soit mise en place une
navette humanitaire entre votre
territoire et les nôtres c'est avec
désarroi que nous entendons aussi votre
appel pour davantage d'armes
vous y avez droit vous en avez besoin la
nation québécoise est pacifique la
nation ukrainienne est pacifique je suis
convaincu que c'est à contrecoeur aussi
que vous sollicitez ces armes vos gens
ont le droit de défendre ceux qu'ils
aiment ils ont le droit de défendre
cette terre qui est la leur alors oui
monsieur le Président qu'on arme les
Ukrainiens vite et plus
monsieur le Président tout ça reste trop
peu trop peu à chaque fois que meurt un
homme une femme un enfant chaque fois
qu'un hôpital une garderie une école un
parc ou une seule fleur sont détruits
chaque fois monsieur le Président chaque
fois
nous crie qu'on en a fait trop peu et
que dans une certaine mesure on l'a fait
trop tard
je me plains à croire Monsieur le
Président qu'il faut distinguer les
peuples de ceux qui les dirigent je me
plains à croire que le peuple le peuple
russe et la première victime du
dictateur du Kremlin
mais il y a des chefs des meneurs des
dirigeants qui parlent bel et bien pour
leur peuple il ne fait aucun doute que
vous en êtes
vous avez su retourner une des pires
armes de l'ennemi contre lui-même la
puissante la vicieuse la mesquine
machine de du prix et de désinformation
du Kremlin a voulu imposer le récit
mensonger d'une histoire réécrite par le
dictateur à son seul profit au profit de
sa seule gloire personnelle
vous avez au contraire
par la simplicité par la franchise par
le courage vous avez forcé la main du
monde entier vous avez maintenu sur
votre peuple le regard de la planète il
se faisant vous avez su et vous devez
encore insister pour davantage obtenir
une aide qui peut-être autrement vous
aurez échappé
vous voyez monsieur le Président ce que
nous ne pouvons pas faire
est-ce qu'il y a de plus cruel
vivre cette guerre ignoble dans des
sous-sols sombres
secoué par le tremblement des bombes
lâché sur vos villes et vos villages
craindre pour ceux que vous aimez
doutez du futur
appréhender une reconstruction qui
durera au moins une génération
avoir peur
contre la peur au ventre des enfants de
l'Ukraine nous ne pouvons que trop peu
je vous prie de nous en excuser
le train et demi monsieur le Président
Nanni le cœur ni le courage ni la force
ni la dignité de vaincre la bravoure du
peuple
ukrainien
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président de leinski vous
vaincre
la liberté vous sera rendu
et à sa modeste mesure le Québec
célébrera avec l'Ukraine merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Blanchet
démocratique monsieur merci monsieur le
président
je souhaite remercier le président
Hélène ski nous avons entendu ces propos
aujourd'hui nous le remercions pour son
courage son inspiration pour sa
résilience nous remercions les
Ukrainiens également pour leur courage
leur résilience
nous a demandé d'imaginer d'imaginer à
quoi ressemblerait
notre vie de se réveiller le matin en
vivant des bombardements comment
expliquer ça nos enfants et comment
expliquer pourquoi nous sommes attaqués
ils nous a demandé comment ils nous a
demandé d'imaginer la perte de 97
enfants il nous a demandé d'imaginer
également les villes de notre grand pays
bombardé pylonnier
vancouverte Toronto Ottawa Montréal et
nous a fait imaginé
des chars d'assaut
d'imaginer des bombes tombées sur le nom
écoles le collectivité hôpitaux
on n'y arrive pas
c'est inimaginable pour le Canada mais
nous avons vu les horaires qui se
déroulent en
Ukraine nous avons bien entendu les mots
du président helenwinski et nous a
demandé de partager la
la peine qu'il vive la souffrance
nous sommes de tout cœur avec eux les
gens se préoccupent sont inquiets il
nous a demandé d'imaginer
tout cela était des et nous il a reconnu
que le Canada est un allié mais il ne
demande de il nous demande davantage les
Canadiens soutiennent l'Ukraine et
répondront à l'appel pour fournir le
plus d'aide possible
les Canadiens veulent faire davantage
les sanctions sont importantes comme l'a
dit le président celanski il faut les
intensifier nous savons que ce que nous
pouvons faire nous savons que le
président Poutine nature des de son pays
des gens mais ce qui lui apporte c'est
sa richesse et la façon de s'attaquer à
lui de lui faire sentir la pression
c'est de cibler cibler la richesse qui
est détenue par ses alliés les oligares
et c'est ce que nous faisons il faut
continuer à appliquer les sons sont les
plus sévères cibler le président pustin
et son cercle
nous savons que nous pouvons fournir de
la duanitaire le Canada a fait sa part
continuera de le faire il faut saluer
donc et accueillir les
Ukrainiens qui cherchent refuge il faut
fournir de l'aide de mammifère sur le
terrain il faut continuer à fournir ce
soutien
demander si on peut imaginer l'horreur
de cette guerre il a demandé si on peut
imaginer la même
guerre se fait plus ici au Canada et
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
imaginer ici et il a demandé qu'on
augmente l'aide et nous devons augmenter
l'aide à l'Ukraine ont devant augmenter
les sanctions nous devons répondre les
besoins des Ukrainiens et on veut et on
va la faire
du discours qu'il a prononcé je pense au
courage que nous avons observé
tous les jours les
Ukrainiens qui
défie cette agression la régression du
président Poutine une chose que nous
dénonçons nous observons beaucoup de
courage et j'ai du mal à trouver les
mots pour décrire pour ma mère m'a
toujours dit il y a une phrase en
punjabi turc bicolore et j'ai toujours
mal compris et elle me disait que ça
signifie d'élever nos esprits
face à l'adversité aux difficultés et ça
m'a rappelé les paroles de ma mère le
courage du président des Ukrainiens je
ne peux penser à autre chose que ce que
me dit à ma mère il faut défier
l'adversité et c'est sont les Ukrainiens
ils disent qu'ils ne vont pas renoncé et
c'est très inspirant nous sommes
inspirés par leur lutte pour la
démocratie la liberté nous sommes en
toute solidarité avec eux ils élèvent
nos esprits et nous serons avec eux
jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
la
leader du Parti vert madame Elvire
prendre la parole c'est président
historique
80 pays de monde il y a quelques jours
mais j'ai reçu cette lettre envoyée par
le président du Parti vert du crâne
nous vous écrivons depuis des
abris anti-bombes depuis notre Ukraine
natale qui est impitoyablement attaqué
bombardé par les forces russes depuis ce
jour fatigué 24 février 2022 les
Ukrainiens sont frappés sans
discernement les dommages collatéraux
s'élèvent à la destruction totale des
villes de nombreuses infrastructures
civiles et sociales n'ont aucune
pertinence pour les militaires sont
elles sont détruites des milliers de
civils sont morts blessés des millions
de personnes fuient leur maison
les volontaires de l'armée ukrainienne
et de la Défense civile ont pris les
armes et se battent pour la survie de
l'Ukraine ils y pervent parviennent dans
une large mesure mais les attaques
aériennes domicile et des bombes causes
de gros dégâts nous sommes impuissants
nous n'avons pas d'armes pour contrer
les attaques aériennes nous vous
demandons de nous soutenir exhorter
votre gouvernement d'aider à protéger
nos cieux en créant une
zone d'exclusion arc aérienne pour
résoudre ce conflits pour un monde fondé
sur des règles et des l'Ukraine
ça me brise le coeur
de m'adresser à mon ami en
Ukraine
et de lui dire qu'une zone d'exclusion
aérienne risquerait une guerre plus
large et même une guerre nucléaire nous
savons que ces raisons sont solides
elles sont creuses à la fois mais nous
devons utiliser tous les outils à notre
disposition mais il semblerait que c'est
inadéquat le Président zellinski on ne
veut pas vous laisser tomber nous
craignons que nous devons vous laisser
tomber mais nous trouverons et nous
aurons recours à tous les moyens et
lorsque c'est moyen ne sont pas de quoi
nous élèves en vrai nous les inventerons
en 56 lors de la crise Suez
[Applaudissements]
on s'aime bien au Canada mais nous
sommes un pays avec peu d'importance du
point de vue de la géopolitique mais
parfois on a des bonnes idées laisse
tomber personne a invité les gardiens de
la paix les casques bleus et il faut
donc mobiliser cette ressource pour ce
Poutine il faut se prévaloir de toutes
les idées il faut se mobiliser pour
stopper cette guerre
nous avons vu donc de nombreuses gares
illégales lancées par des super
puissances et basées sur des mensonges
en Vietnam en Afghanistan en Irak et non
il faut il faut arrêter les
bombardements il faut avoir un Cécile
feu il faut faire en sorte d'asseoir
Vladimir Poutine à la table de
négociation et de trouver une solution
pour la paix
et il faut l'arrêter avec la vérité avec
le courage des Ukrainiens avec
cette réalité si atroce et
j'exhorte les démocrates du monde entier
vous avez beaucoup de courage vous avez
vous nous avez tous inspiré on ne peut
vous laisser tomber parce que vous ne le
ferez pas nous devons faire davantage
nous le savons et comme l'a dit notre
premier ministre vous êtes un champion
de la démocratie et il faut être digne
de vous et il faut faire en sorte de
vous appuyer non arrêtons ces pertes de
vie arrêtons
donc stoppons les plats redémarres
russes qui pleurent leur soldats et
pensons aux Russes qui s'opposent à la
gare et qui se retrouve en prison disant
non à la guerre
[Applaudissements]
et je conclurai
avec ceci je prie pour vous constamment
et je prie pour l'Ukraine et je souhaite
que vous veniez ici en personne et qu'on
vous invite et que nous voyons en chair
et en os le président d'un pays en paix
d'un pays libre et démocratique un prix
un pays victorieux nous souhaitons vous
inviter lorsque l'Ukraine sera
victorieuse vous êtes l'ami l'ami de
tous les Canadiens merci
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame
le président de nous avoir adressé la
parole je sais que nous nous
souviendrons longtemps de cet homme
exceptionnel
S
ou par la vidéo
à cet événement
il s'agit d'un événement historique que
nous avons vécu ensemble merci Jacky
[Applaudissements]
alors encore une fois des
applaudissements extrêmement nourri à la
suite de ces allocutions qui ont été
prononcées cette fois-ci par les
différents chefs des parties
d'opposition des discours parfois très
émouvants comme celui de Madame may chef
du Parti vert qui a conclu cette série
de discours je retourne à mes invités
alors avec moi Louis Blouin mon collègue
que je retrouve Ottawa et Dominique
Carel qui est politologue qui est un
expert de l'Ukraine aussi merci encore
messieurs d'être avec moi à ce moment-ci
monsieur ARL je commençais avec vous il
y avait beaucoup d'émotions c'était très
très senti est-ce que des discours qui
vous ont marqué plus que d'autres dans
tous ceux qu'on a entendus
c'était tous de très très bon discours
peut-être au niveau de ce qui le
discours de Madame né à la fin
évidemment joue beaucoup sur mon fin le
personnel
les émotions la lettre qu'elle aurait su
le de son collègue du Parti vert du
crâne on voyait sa voie brisée par
l'émotion mais peut-être ce qui ce que
je retiens il y a beaucoup de choses que
j'ai retenu mais dans le discours de
Monsieur Blanchet lorsqu'il parle de la
façon dont Hélène ski et parvenu à
retourner l'arme
russe qui nous fait si peur depuis
plusieurs années et là on parle pas de
lance de l'anse missile dont on parle de
l'arme de la désinformation
et lorsque Monsieur Trudeau dans son
allocution au tout début parler de
Monsieur zirinski comme un champion de
la démocratie ce qui a amené à une
innovation d'une ou deux minutes c'est
le lien en fait avec ce que les
démocraties au Canada et ailleurs vivent
depuis plusieurs années avec le
mouvement Trump les mouvements
populistes la désinformation pendant la
covid l'Ukraine c'est une démocratie
aussi la seule en fait dans cette région
là et ça c'est une démocratie lorsque
Zelenski nous dit nous appelle nous les
Canadiens des amis de la vérité
ça va nous chercher c'est la vérité
c'est ce qu'on voit pas la télévision
russe mais on voit sur toutes les
chaînes de télévision au monde c'est
c'est ce que nous dit
Zelinski et la vérité c'est un peuple
qui littéralement se bat pour sa survie
la survie de son état dans une unité
dans un élan comme ça qui est
extrêmement
émouvant et inspirant effectivement
beaucoup d'émotions parce qu'on parle
d'une réalité comme vous le dites qu'on
voit devant nos yeux jour après jour
avec la couverture journalistique avec
ces images aussi qui se promènent sur
les réseaux sociaux et avec tous ces
témoignages parce que beaucoup de gens
aussi ben là je parle pour les réseaux
français évidemment qui nous ont accordé
des entrevues en français d'ailleurs ça
étonne beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs
monsieur Harel peut-être que vous avez
la réponse à ce niveau-là il y a
beaucoup de gens en Ukraine qui parle
français
oui faudrait peut-être entre autres
saluer
l'initiative de nos cousins c'est à dire
la France et qui a un réseau
exceptionnel à travers le monde mais
aussi en Ukraine d'institutions
culturelles qui inclut évidemment des
écoles afin de pour apprendre le
français le sait comme ça que les
beaucoup de craignons ont pris le
français en fait moi quand j'ai commencé
quand j'ai commencé avec mes collègues
français participer à organiser des
écoles d'été c'était financé par
l'Ambassade de France en Ukraine avec
l'Institut français il y avait tout le
côté francophile et on le voit là on le
voit maintenant en direct avec des
témoignages dans notre langue ici au
Québec d'autant plus grande le fait
qu'on partage à ce moment-là la même
langue donc les témoignages sont encore
plus frappants le phénomène
identification en réalité devient très
très fort Louis je retourne à vous sur
le site plan politique maintenant avec
le positionnement de nos parties
d'opposition ici on va quand même qu'il
y avait certaines différences dans
la solidarité elle était à l'unisson on
l'a bien entendu mais effectivement moi
il y a une chose que je note en
particulier c'est Madame burgen la chef
intérimaire du Parti conservateur qui a
dit son erreur pour la première fois que
le Parti conservateur était en faveur
d'une exclusion aérienne donc une
protection du ciel de l'Ukraine en tout
cas pour ce qui a trait au corridor
humanitaire donc on prévoit une
exclusion aérienne pour certaines zones
pour permettre justement l'acheminement
de denrées aux besoins l'évacuation de
gens aussi si nécessaire alors madame
burgen qui va un petit peu plus loin
parce que jusqu'ici le gouvernement
Trudeau dit écoutez on ne veut pas
franchir cette ligne là ils ont peur de
l'escalade ils ont peur d'en venir au
troisième conflit mondial est-ce que
cette position là pour échanger monsieur
Harel le faisait bien changer il y a
plein de choses il le faisais bien
remarquer tout à l'heure il y a plein de
choses qu'on imaginait impossible il y a
quelques semaines à peine alors on verra
bien là-dessus mais madame Joly nous a
dit tantôt qu'on était pas là pas non
plus pour l'adhésion de l'OTAN de la
l'Ukraine à l'automne alors poste une
chose que je remarque j'ai entendu aussi
le chef bloquiste monsieur Blanchet qui
a tenu à souligner que la nation
québécoise spécifiquement était derrière
les Ukrainiens monsieur sing lui NPD qui
a essayé de reprendre un peu cette
manière de faire de Monsieur zeninsky
dans son discours de dire il faut se
mettre dans les souliers des Ukrainiens
actuellement comprendre ce que ce qu'ils
vivent lui aussi voulait marquer des
esprits de cette manière là et puis
évidemment ce discours très marquant
aussi de la représentante du Parti vert
elisabethmée qui elle aussi a vraiment
avait tout un magasininé cette douleur
on le voyait bien qui a essayé de
l'exprimer qui a sans doute été je pense
la plus émue elle pleurait à certains
moments pendant ce discours là on voit
bien le souci l'impuissance et je suis
désolé mais à cette demande d'exclusion
aérienne on fait ça c'était ça sa
position aussi elle dit nous devons nous
dire non et et et on la sentait contrer
ton la santé on sentait que c'est
douloureux pour elle d'avoir à dire cela
il faut comprendre Julie que tous ces
députés députés c'est sénateur était là
aujourd'hui il reçoivent une tonne de
courriels de lettres de Canadiens
d'origine ukrainienne mais aussi le
canadienne de manière générale qui
veulent aider qui veulent en savoir qui
veulent en faire plus qui veulent
pouvoir accueillir des gens le plus
rapidement possible alors la pression
sur les parlementaires canadiens elle
est très très élevée également monsieur
Harel dans ce que Monsieur Blanchet du
chef que chef fait du Bloc québécois a
dit il y a quelque chose qui m'a frappé
aussi il a dit j'espère que les
sanctions économiques vont avoir un tel
effet qui va y avoir une pression à
l'interne au sein même de la Russie pour
forcer monsieur Poutine arrêté est-ce
que ça effectivement on commence à le
sentir vous avez vu hier ce geste
tellement audacieux d'une réalisatrice
ou productrice russe qui a risqué elle
risque la suite de sa vie en brandissant
cette pancarte en disant nous dans les
médias on vous ment il y a une guerre
actuellement en Ukraine les Russes sont
derrière ça est-ce que vous sentez que
c'est un mouvement qui est grandissant
au sein de la Russie
écoutez il faut saluer son courage inouï
elle risque carrément là avec la
nouvelle loi 15 ans de prison pour ce
simple geste il y a des manifestations
qui sont réprimées à chaque fin de
semaine
il y a une très très forte répression en
Russie est-ce que ça va influencer
encore une fois le président Poutine qui
est essentiellement le pouvoir
pratiquement absolu dans le système
politique russe
ça reste à voir ça reste à voir
si il fallait que le régime commence à
craquer j'ai pas l'impression que ça va
venir d'en bas c'est à dire de la rue ou
des ou du courage là de des Russes mais
plutôt dans haut des services de
sécurité parce que le système politique
russe c'est un système essentiellement
de c'est une alliance entre l'armée et
la police surtout la police puisque
Poutine lui-même venait de la police
secrète ce qu'on appelait le KGB à
l'époque c'est à ce moment-là mais
encore une fois il faut pas se faire des
lusions c'est un régime qui est très
très fort à l'interne en fait qui le
niveau de contrôle actuellement commence
de plus en plus à ressembler au système
soviétique
des pires années des pires années en
termes de encore une fois de répression
on vient de nous signaler une dépêche
vous la lit en direct cette
protestataire dont on vient de parler le
qui a eu ce geste déclin à la télé a été
condamné une amende et libérée parce que
vous savez on était sans nouvelles
d'elle et les gens la chercher se
demander où est-ce qu'elle est rendue
alors elle est libérée on verra la suite
ça veut pas dire qu'elle va échapper à
long terme à une peine de prison on
verra s'il y aura un procès enfin on va
voir comment les choses vont se
développer un mot de la fin il nous
reste une minute à peine monsieur
arrêtez ces missions accomplies quand
même là pour cette première portion de
la journée parce qu'évidemment ça va se
décliner avec d'autres réactions dans
les heures qui vont suivre mais pour
l'instant pour Monsieur Zelinski
qu'est-ce que c'est mission accomplie
avec cette allocution Canada je crois
que oui évidemment il vient nous
chercher au niveau des émotions et comme
Monsieur sing nous a dit dans les
fossilver dans l'adversité comme sa mère
lui disait là c'est là il faut que nous
élever nos esprits dans l'adversité mais
aussi au niveau politique on voit les le
chef de l'opposition qui est
essentiellement sont demandeus au
gouvernement
il faut en faire plus il faut en faire
plus donc le gouvernement est sous
pression d'en faire encore plus d'être
créatif comme comme Madame mais le
souligné en quelque secondes lui je
pense que Monsieur Trudeau lui a rempli
aussi son objectif politique c'est de
montrer qu'il est au devant de cette
crise qu'il est un acteur clé ça c'est
certain mais en même temps le revers de
ça c'est qu'il fait monter les attentes
quand le président ukrainien vient la
chambre comme ça et répète toutes ces
demandes sur pour le temps notamment
alors pour Monsieur Trudeau c'est clair
que ça représente certaines pression sur
lui pour continuer de mener la charge
mais là le coffre à outils des sanctions
canadiennes là il commence à être pas
mal vide Julie parce que tellement de
choses qui ont été annoncées ces
derniers jours alors lui le défi c'est
de continuer à montrer qu'il peut
montrer la voie de ses alliés monsieur
je vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui pour vivre ce
moment très solonel le moment qui est
historique réellement avec cette
allocution du Président Zelinski
président ukrainien au Canada merci
Louis Blouin merci beaucoup dans un
instant on va passer à Sébastien
Beauvais c'est mordu politique et on va
vous laisser sur ces images de la
Chambre des communes ou les députés ont
longuement applaudis le président
ukrainien une fois son allocution
terminée alors si vous voulez d'autres
nouvelles aussi c'est sur le site de
Radio-Canada
merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]